how do you balance the thought between
live your life as it is right now and
worrying about the future my anxiety
about the future often makes me not
enjoy the life I currently have so we
just did an episode on anxiety Ryan and
this question is appropriate because
what fira is trying to balance is what
is going on in my life right now yeah
and then I'm also worried about the
future now you can think about the
future sure without worrying about the
future I think there's two different
things now fira here just by thinking
about the future is sort of presupposing
and no matter what she does to think
about the future she's gonna be worrying
about the future now I want to live a
life that my future self is going to be
proud of so I want to live a life that
is congruent well right now my daily
actions today are congruent with the
person I want to be a year from now five
years from now ten years from now and so
that way I'm not gonna be worried about
the future I'm going to be anticipating
the future for what it is and living in
the moment for me means making sure that
I'm congruent there's some sort of
congruence between the person I want to
be and the actions I take right now yeah
so I mean step number one sounds like
fira has got to get clear on what her
values and beliefs are yeah because I
mean ultimately when when I think about
living a meaningful life when I think
about you know what is happiness and I
say happiness as a not as in like
endorphins hitting my head and being
happy but living a meaningful life and
Happiness longer-term well-being
yeah is interchangeable for me it's when
my short term actions align with my long
term values and beliefs and if I'm not
clear on those values and beliefs well
then I'm gonna be lost until I figure
out what those are so step number one is
yes figure out what those values and
beliefs are I mean I can't tell you I
mean how many times have we we talked
about that I can't tell you how many
mentoring students I've had and like
that's where we start getting clear on
their values and beliefs because that is
the compass that's that is that is the
guide for what you should take action
on every single day and when something
is off balance when you're not able to
live in the moment that compass really
helps yeah I think your your beliefs
need to be anchored in your values
because if not the the so our beliefs of
the past that get us to the destination
the destination being the values and
quite often we might have a bunch of
beliefs we don't know why we believe
them mm-hmm and that becomes a problem
as well where our beliefs are often
someone else's beliefs and we don't know
how we got there or actually where we're
going won't know how we got on that path
that belief and we don't really know
where it's taking us and so I think it's
really important to start with those
values and then you figure out how do I
get to to where I'm going absolutely man
that another tool that I will recommend
for fara is your calendar like this for
me is so important because the calendar
helps me plan ahead for you know not
just staying on top of my adult
responsibilities but also for my free
time for for one more recording a
podcast but having having everything
scheduled out and being able to know
where I'm supposed to be when I'm
supposed to be there that helps me to
live more in the moment because I'm not
so paranoid but oh did I forget
something today I do like sometimes I'll
wake up in the morning and I'm like
where am I gonna be today and I'll pull
up the calendar and I'm like oh I don't
have to be anywhere today oh that's
right yeah like and I can look at that
and I can instantly let that anxiety go
and you realize you're doing what you're
supposed to be dead that's why you let
the anxiety go exactly and then the
other thing too man this is a I mean I
would recommend this for anyone but for
me man like you and I were just talking
about before this podcast the how Mariah
and I have been doing this budget over
the last couple months and how it has
affected you know different things in
our lives but what I'll say man is like
knowing where every dollar is gonna go
and having a plan for that dude that
takes off so much anxiety not just for
the month but for retirement for
everything else man like so
so really you're thinking about the few
yeah don't worrying about exactly man so
maybe like this is a this is my way of
saying Farah you need to find tools to
use in your life that help you to plan
for the future so that you don't have to
constantly be worrying about what is
happening in the future yeah and so some
of those tools are using your calendar
effectively and scheduling as much as
you can including some of things that I
schedule our time just to mess around on
YouTube for an hour yeah I did this last
night actually by the if I had my
workday done and so from 7:00 until 9:00
p.m. I watched unnecessary YouTube
videos and come and and I felt good
about it because I had planned for it
ahead of time and so I didn't I didn't
feel like well should I be doing
something else right now no this was the
best use of my time because I had
planned for it accordingly now of course
you can over plan you can plan a bunch
of nonsense for your day you have to be
honest with yourself when you're using
these tools you have to use them
effectively a hammer is a tool but if I
use it to just beat Jordan over the head
with it he's not gonna be happy about it
and our videos would suck but do you
know it's funny like we planned
vacations yes and like vacations are
these times it's our it's giving
ourselves permission to go somewhere and
pretty much do whatever we want with
that time that we have set aside and you
know planning a week vacation is is is
great but planning a little our vacation
is great do we all have to we all have
to veg you know minimalism is not about
staying productive 24 hours a day no
it's not about constantly be working
towards this mass of making a dent in
the universe get things done minimalism
is about it's about keeping our keeping
ourselves sane in this insane world that
we live in right and and yes like part
of for me even though I'm a huge
extrovert man like I still need to veg
out and Mariah and I we will sit and
watch you know stupid reruns of well
they're not stupid they're hilarious of
you know Seinfeld or the office or
whatever it may be
but but yes there's no shame in there's
no shame in vegging out there's no shame
in watching unnecessary YouTube videos
the only the only time where I feel
shame when I do that stuff is when I
know I should be doing something else
but if you schedule the time to do it
yeah there's no reason to feel guilty
the reason that you feel anxious quite
often is because of the many
distractions that are out there there is
this fear of missing out because we're
constantly bombarded by endless messages
yeah do this do this do this and we feel
like we're missing out and that produces
anxiety now you can reduce the number
you can filter out the number of inputs
if we get 500,000 discrete inputs every
day there's no way that we can filter
through all of them but what we can do
is put up some walls some barriers we
can remove the social media apps from
our phone yeah we can agree to check our
email once or twice a day at scheduled
times we can agree to not spend more
than an hour a day watching television
we can agree to use the calendar we can
agree to use a budgeting app like every
dollar you we can agree to use for me I
use a today list now that's a do list a
today list to really figure out what my
priorities are that eliminates the many
distractions that I have if we get rid
of those distractions the anxiety level
decreases dramatically absolutely one
other thing don't confuse ephemeral
happiness with long-term well-being hmm
another essay from our friend Colin
right it's up on our website right now
it's called eudaimonia we'll put a link
to it in the show notes it's a different
kind of happiness quite often we think
of happiness as as this momentary burst
of pleasure yeah I've got a
five-year-old daughter and Ella is
always in the moment they're kids
five-year-olds especially are really
great at being in the moment they don't
have to worry about you know retirement
right nothing I want to worry about it
they don't have to think about yeah
right yeah and so they don't do much
thinking in fact if I asked her what she
did yesterday the answer is almost I
have no idea I don't know I don't know
cuz they're so focused on the right here
and right now and that can be great as
long as you are also thinking about the
the future and in the future
consequences that's why as adults we
have fully developed frontal cortexes we
have to think about both and so this sa
eudaimonia really talks about balancing
out that short term a static pleasure mm
with long term well-being
yeah I'm less concerned now with the oh
my god I have to feel excited in every
moment what about expectation is so bad
and that's why kids have tantrums is
because they don't have that as soon as
they lose that in the moment excitedness
it's oh my god I'm freaking out
yeah instead let's worry about long term
well-being well being in the moment but
also does this lead to my future
well-being and that term is called
eudaimonia
yeah and so take a look at that essay
we'll put a link to that if you're
watching this on youtube you can
probably see it on the screen as well
you